hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel sorry if the lighting is a
little bit weird right now I am
recording at night reasoning being that
I procrastinated too long due to looking
at my fantasy football team and trying
to make trades and then I had to roster
bait right after that so anyways now
that I've completed let's go ahead and
get into some systems designed for the
day we will be talking about reddis and
memcached all right so before we jump
into this one let's just do a very quick
refresher on some certain types of
caching that we've seen throughout Compu
in the most obvious one is probably the
one that comes with your CPU and that
would be things like L1 L2 and L3 cache
you've also just got individual device
cache a good example of this would be an
app on your mobile phone for example
with Google Drive typically you'll
download a copy of the thing that you're
storing in the cloud so that if you
don't have access to Internet you can go
ahead and access it
locally another thing would be an
example of caching on your application
server so if we have a server right here
and we've got a database right there
maybe we'll actually go ahead and save
some of the results from our database in
the cache so that if the user ever goes
ahead and requests them again we can
just quickly return it from our server
however this comes with a problem like
we've spoken about in the past when your
cash is actually tied to a physical
device or something like that it is
literally limited by the capacity of the
device itself and so as a result
sometimes we want our own separate
caching layer and in distributed
computing the way we might do this is
with something like reddis or mcash so
what are the upsides and downsides to
recap well basically it is a little bit
more complex because now you might have
to add and manage separate components
but at the same time and this is the
most important part it scales
independently so if we need a ton of
cash because most of our requests are
basically the same and we really don't
need much computing power on our servers
we can have a ton of cach and only one
server and one database node at the same
time if we need a ton of databases but
very little cash well we can do that too
so let's go ahead and talk about data
storage as I zoom in and basically one
thing about caches is that you know
typically we want them to offer us some
sort of performance boost and there are
a couple ways that you can do this one
is when the data itself is being stored
somewhere physically closer to the user
a good example of that would be the
Google Drive example uh where you know
for example you would write to a
document and then eventually that gets
uploaded to a cloud but that's done
asynchronously and the right to your
local hard drive is basically a right
back cash and it's faster because it is
located closer in proximity to your
device but if that makes a little bit
less sense the point is some caches are
closer to you and some caches are
literally just Faster by
storage and that is going to be the case
for RIS and mcash the reasoning why is
that they both store data in memory and
so we've seen a couple of inmemory
storage systems so far on this channel
and the one that I've spoken about the
most in this series would be volt DB so
if you haven't watched The Volt DB video
it's not too important for this one but
the gist is that is effectively also an
in-memory storage but it's also a
relational database and so that comes
with a lot of guarantees that we don't
necessarily need here because for our
cache what we really care more so about
is just having a key value store and so
it is going to be non-relational that's
going to be the case for both redus and
mcash so let's start by talking about
mcash first because it's a little bit
more basic and then reddish kind of
Builds on top of it so mcash is a super
Bare Bones in memory store and we can go
ahead and scale this thing out by having
a bunch of nodes making it distributed
all that fun stuff so if we do make it
distributed obviously we want some sort
of partitioning right fortunately mcash
does support that fors out of the box
using a consistent hash ring so as we
have right here in my little diagram
basically everything in this range for
example on the like consistent hashing
ring if this was like Keys a through J
or something would be stored from uh on
node one and then the same thing over
here all going to be stored on node two
and then the same thing over here all
going to be stored on node 3 Now using
consistent hashing is super useful
because it means that the same requests
are going to be getting routed to the
same cache hence the same data will be
going to the same users so for example
if I want my Facebook profile cached
it's probably going to be good that I'm
getting sent to the right cache every
single time where my data actually lives
so that's useful then we've also got
multi-threading now in theory you would
think well that's not that big of a deal
pretty much every database has
multi-threading well guess what maybe
redus doesn't so we'll talk about that
in a second and then finally just as a
quick throwback to last video it also
does use a least recently used eviction
policy so how do we Implement that let's
remember doubly linked
list with a
hashmap the reason being that let's say
this is the head of the list this is the
the tail we evict from the tail if I
were to go ahead and read this node
right here then the fact that I have
this hashmap allows me to figure out
where it is and then move it back around
to the Head anyways that's a bit of a
tangent now let's go ahead and move on
to redis and talk about that a little
bit so the main benefit that reddis
offers over mcash is that it's super
feature Rich as opposed to just being
like a very simple in memory key value
store you can use hashmaps you can use
sorted sets you can even use Geo indexes
and all of those are implemented in
memory which is really great so as
opposed to mcash which just does
partitioning via consistent hashing and
having a variable number of partitions
in the case of redus we actually have a
fixed number of partitions and which
partition goes where is basically
communicated via a gossip protocol so
let's imagine every single one of these
guys has three partitions on it so there
are 12 fixed partitions in the system if
this guy were to go down then you'll see
that we're going to move move one of its
partitions to every single one of the
nodes and we can do that because
basically these guys are going to say oh
is this thing down I think so is this
thing down I think so and then once they
all agree then partitions start getting
moved around okay cool another useful
thing that we've got with redis is a
right ahead log so I didn't mention that
in mcash but of course what that right
ahead log is going to allow us to do is
make Atomic operations because we can
first commit them to the right ahead log
and then we can actually write them in
memory that way if our machine were to
go down in the middle of it we can look
at our right ahead log and say well were
we supposed to actually write this thing
if not well abort it if so commit it and
so that way we can have Atomic uh
basically operations the next thing that
is important to ensure acid transactions
which we can do in redus is ensuring
isolation so how does redus do that well
it actually just runs things single
threadly and so what we end up doing is
achieving actual serial execution kind
of similar to volti actually so again
this allows us to have actual
transactions in reddis which can be
really useful if you want those type of
data guarantees I'm not saying it's
impossible with mcast either it's just
that you're probably going to have to
implement that type of locking yourself
then finally reddis while it is feature
Rich also kind of forces you to use
single leader replication it's good
because it kind of configures that out
of the box for you but at the same time
now you're stuck to that Paradigm so as
a quick conclusion before I get ready to
go go to sleep distributed caches like I
mentioned are really great because you
can scale them independently you can
have as much or as little capacity as
you really need and redus and mcash are
two really good solutions for achieving
that goal that being said they do differ
slightly I think redus is a little bit
more of a managed solution if you're a
solo developer or something and you just
need something to hold you over I feel
like Rus is probably going to make your
life easier that being said if you need
some super complex caching setup you
have the developers and you know the
complexity is required well maybe you
might actually need multi-leader
leaderless replication maybe you do need
some sort of special type of locking and
as a result maybe M cash might be the
better option for you so while it does
offer a little bit more flexibility in
my opinion it seems to be a little bit
less convenient so I'd say that's
probably the main trade-off there
anyways guys I hope you enjoyed this
video we're starting to see the light at
the end of the tunnel and I'm looking
forward to doing the interviews